so look what putin is doing is
absolutely barbaric and evil and this
government is determined to stand with
ukraine and that means imposing
sanctions and that means on people like
roman abramovich
so our focus here is to ensure that we
applied for licence
in order to protect the game the club
and its funds
and so that's what we've done here roman
abramovich cannot benefit from the club
but it is important to note that fans
can still who have existing tickets and
existing season ticket holders can still
go to matches the match will still go
ahead on sunday they can still go to the
away matches those working at the club
will still be paid and players can still
play look i'm going to get into the
weeds of what will happen in the future
in terms of the sale of chelsea that
will depend on the terms of a license
which will be issued by the treasury but
at the moment he cannot benefit from
revenue from the club and he cannot
benefit from the sale of the club
abramovic has links to putin who is
who is mounting a barbaric and evil
attack against the people of ukraine
this government we in this department
stand with the people of ukraine and as
i've said i'm afraid sanctions have
consequences abramovic's actions have
consequences too i am worried about the
couple because obviously
look at look at their rudiger christian
asperger
they can't find new contracts we haven't
got many defendants as well we have got
many defenders but we're not
we've come next season we're not going
to be backed up in the defence so come
next season we might be struggling if
the sanctions don't lift and all that so
hopefully
we it all
all ends and we get new contracts in for
him
when you really look it on paper it's
not the worst but it definitely bites
you like i'm on my way to norwich now
this is going to be my last away day
till the end the season
thankfully still got a season ticket so
we can do home games at least but we're
still going to be hurt with the fact
that it's only 25 000. i'm really really
sad and i'm emotionally very
very very stressful about the situation
the ascension that we read on the social
medias
it gives me anxiety and all this stuff
so i want to see my club one more time
before i leave and i don't know where it
is going to be in future